good evening ladies and gentlemen today
I'll be talking about toilets I have in
my previous career have managed pretty
large construction projects airport
terminals and constructions but I'm
finding this project one of the most
exciting so I'm going to just take the
liberty of sharing some of those ideas
with you I'm sure most of you would know
mr. gates besides the one of the richest
person on earth at the moment he's one
of the very active philanthropist I
didn't realize that the money that he is
putting the foundation is basically it's
personal money and it has nothing to do
with the microsoft corporation so the
foundation is going on for some time and
they have I think they have a portfolio
four billion dollars at the moment
including lots of vaccine preparation
agriculture and one of the program is
water sanitation and health hygiene
there are two main components of that
one is basically supporting a
conventional water and sanitation with
the view to increased access to safe
water and safe sanitation but they have
also come up with another stream of
program which try to really shake the
whole sector by challenging the experts
to come up with new ideas I think there
is a realization that many of these
ideas may not work but there is a
reasonable chance that some of those
could turn into other individually or in
combination game changes in the sector
so
that's that happened on fourteenth of
august this year when after our first
phase we were asked to go and present
our prototype in Seattle in front of the
panels and I was given in the end 5 to 6
minutes and I was constrained to do
three slides in front of mr. gates and
after that we were given the second
prize were on a concept we were beaten
by Caltech but we sort of were ahead of
a Stanford and some other universities
so basically if you look at this these
pictures what what we have proposed is
to convert just these this is basically
fecal sludge or we are basically [ __ ]
which is very hazardous and harmful and
through the process we are trying to
convert that into valuable material safe
to touch and these are the real pictures
and I forgot to bring some samples
because because it is it is it is most
like coffee apologies to coffee lovers
or caramel and and that you can feel the
granules of that so basically what we
are trying to do is to before I go on
that let me give the bigger picture 3.2
billion people at the moment don't have
toilets the people who have toilets you
don't really know where the excreta is
going well there's treat it or not even
in Europe there are cities where human
excreta is more or less Dumpty straight
into fresh waters and there's a whole
implication of that so it is not just
the developing countries issue and if
you think about health costs and things
diarrhea there's lost thousands thousand
children are dying every minute as we
speak because of lack of toilets
so basically we we we want to have
toilet which basically the desirable so
if you go to many countries you don't
want to use Lou because they are so
dirty they smelly and and it's very hard
to go in so I think in our team we have
people from designer school from
chemical engineering from civil
engineering and from materials working
together to create a desirable space in
toilet so that you can also treat your
toilets respectfully now why we are
doing that because I think studies have
shown Wallbanger thing that we have the
least willingness to pay for our toilet
or sanitation as compared to highest
willingness to pay let's say for power
and telecommunication and that creates
lots of problem for developing any
business case for investment we think
along with just treating the normal
fecal sludge we will be exploring the
weather mention hygiene waste could also
be treated because that is one of the
things which we don't talk about but
there are many countries where there's a
huge loss of students when they reach to
that stage because you don't have
toilets to deal with that menstrual
hygiene waste so we are thinking about
whether some of the technologies we are
going to expect to develop could also
treat organic aspects of that waste then
we have a market in a besides the
developing countries even in states and
here where you don't really have piped
or network connections you have big
gatherings i was told that this year
glastonbury festival was postponed and
one of the reason was that they didn't
have the toilets because all toilets
will move to olympic i don't know but
but there are also big gatherings where
you do need to stand alone
mobile toilets and you don't have the
real connection into the system so what
we want to do is do is something which
is desirable for users self-cleaning so
we don't want to use quite a lot of
water because at the moment if you think
about that that you know if I if I
remember correctly the figure is like
half half a kilogram of excreta that we
produce an adult produced in many
societies and then you use for each
flush like five litre of water and we
use we use all of that thing and we
transported miles and miles and then we
treat using lots of energy and lots of
space so apparently common sense tells
you that maybe it's not that smart to
transport the whole thing and then you
treated in a very resource-intensive way
so we want to to to to make it smart the
challenge is to to to make it easy to
maintain so we are experimenting with
some sort of nanoucoco which basically
reduce the stickiness of material with
that cultural acceptability world can be
divided into people who sit and people
who escort people who wash and people
who wipe and there are associated
difficulties with what you design i've
come across some people you know using
material and then trying to flush and in
one case i saw people using you know
rocks in some hilly area and trying to
just flush it and we we would given this
a remit that it should be non piped
solution and it has to have least
dependency on energy sources
so we before I go on that so what we did
was basically the principle is very
simple there are some discussion about
energy there is a very good link between
what we eat and what we excrete so when
you eat you have some calorific value on
food you know 2,000 calories we eat the
thing is what comes out it still has
some energy and the figures people shows
using different diets is from 5 to 20
mega joules per dry mass so the idea is
the weather we can recover some of that
energy from from something that which we
try to just treat and not use so that is
one the process that we are trying to
use is called hydrothermal colonization
which basically occurs naturally in
converting you know material into you
know like sludge into coal but that
happens over millions of years what we
are trying to do is to achieve that in a
very short period of time and again very
simply it is basically sort of pressure
cooker where basically you try to get
the heat up to 200 degree centigrade
under 20 bar pressure which basically
kills almost every any sort of known
germs and things and convert the
material and what comes out of it
basically three streams of things some
solid suspension which we could extract
and use for combustion or we can use for
soil soil improver liquid stream we
could we could extract you know somewhat
years nitrates and gas which we are
thinking of you know moving back into
the system so very simple principle you
know linkages between the energy we take
in and what we can recover natural
process and then try to to to use that
as much as possible to run on its own
this is not a toilet if you are
visualizing where the toilet ago but
just that a prototype to show our sort
of a concept so if you think about and
if you want to visualize that you may
have toilet somewhere there and the
waste is collected in this in a
collector very simply then we have a
pump now we are using pump at the moment
but that could be replaced by a solar
powered or some sort of it is like a
year it is I think 1.5 you know a lot
less energy so basically that the real
thing which is happening is in this
reactor which again you know to show the
process we have used off-the-shelf
components this is basically a heat
exchanger it has three tubes inside so
material goes and pass through in three
loops and by the time it reached there
it has attained the temperature then
basically material goes up we'd sort of
like reduce the pressure and then the
liquids and gases are collected
basically this prototype you know
basically could could be used 100 users
now because I phase one which was
basically to prove our concept was to to
do exactly that because what what is
needed is ultimately to have household
toilet which are using new principles so
that is the prototype which we took to
settle it doesn't look like toilet but
it shows the principle now what I'm
going to do before I here we go to
question and answer thing is to just to
recap that in June May June 2011 Gates
Foundation invited 25 universities they
selected eight universities including
our university to come up with ideas and
then they gave this this price to three
universities Celtic ourselves and tour
two different technologies are being
proposed and recently we have got
funding for the phase two and the
challenge now is to develop this concept
into technology readiness level 7 which
basically is lab tested system operating
in operational environment and we all
are very excited to work towards that we
haven't finally resolve all the issues
or we think that we are on roads to some
game-changing technologies Thank you
Thank You Sahel now who would like to
ask a question on reinventing humble lou
fellow panelists no less icare elite
University of Birmingham um how do you
deal with changes in pH I mean say
someone's sick in the toilet but not
when that changed the the bacterial
flora you see our sort of the thing is
at 140 degree centigrade and above we
think all sorts of germs will be burned
so in terms of dealing with pH and
things of course and and of course the
whole the big issue is that if let's say
all of a sudden you have a party in a
house and there's lots of beer and then
all of a sudden your your your
proportion of solid you know becomes
like less than eight person because the
idea is that you need to have certain
amount of solids to produce the energy
so if your proportion become less than
eight person how almost liquid and what
you do with that these are the kinds of
questions that we are sort of
considering but there are some large
plants already operating HTC dealing
with solid waste vertically in Germany
and Switzerland where they are using
twenty five to thirty percent of our
proportion but I think these are the
kinds of things will be looking at and
especially the big challenge is how we
can reduce the scale because we need a
household toilet but then in house
we may not have the energy another
brother a mass to generate the energy so
we may have to compromise a better we
may think about like rather than having
just you know 20 users we say look at
the minimum would be from 3,200 or above
thank you to Gary for raising the
Saturday night clubbing objections about
anyone else got a question look I think
you've web the ball into silence with
the reinvented oh I mean I just have a
practical which may have crossed
people's minds which is simply cost I
mean you've alluded to it there that you
might have to sort of upscale to start
with I mean even simpler new leu
technologies I got carried away with a
clock well architect recently and an
almost agree to having something where
you washed your hands and then you use
the waste water for for the toilet you
then turn out it costs to 9,000 pounds
it's just so I mean have you thought
about how quickly you could get costs to
a level that is horrible the target that
set is like point zero five or 5 cents
per user per day is the is the target
that we are inning like sixty dollars
per family per month but my point is if
it's already so expensive to do
something sounds a bit simpler just to
use waste water then everything is what
you're trying to know what maybe you're
not adding in that it's not just that
cost but maybe 20,000 pounds per family
that the sort of incurring the UK for
the pipes and everything that's not
really counted so the thing is that our
existing system is really very expensive
so I think I think you have a point and
I thought all depends on the standards
as well so I think our design team along
with the other grantees will be looking
into because I think we do want to have
like market segmentation so we can think
of like people who can spend lots of
money on that and also people who are
poorest of the poor in developing
countries to afford but that's the
target that we are aiming to fascinating
thank you very much thank you
you